one two three one two three what's going
on guys this is Rob and I'm doing a Days
of Future past Q&A and my cats meowing I
guess maybe my cat wants to be part of
the discussion I don't know but as I
promised I have answers you guys have
questions or maybe it should be you guys
have questions I have answers I don't
know it doesn't really matter but I've
never really done anything like this
before so I have no idea how it's gonna
go so it might be a little bit bumpy it
might be kind of a rough ride but I
think we'll get through in one piece so
so what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
kind of scroll through YouTube I'm gonna
scroll through the comments that you
guys left some of the comments some of
the questions that you guys had were
answered by subscribers which is great
that's really what I've been looking
forward to you that's really what I was
hoping what happened is that some of you
guys would kind of take up the mantle
and and take up the role of answering
questions you know that people had but
some of the questions that were answered
were answered in ways where I thought I
could use a little more explanation and
so I'll you know for those I'll go ahead
and expand a little bit further but I'm
starting with the first question
starting with the top the first question
was does the Days of Future past link to
the age of Ultron no it does not under
no circumstances can I really envision a
scenario where that would happen and the
comics that never happened and there are
two different universes as it was
explained by by Erik Channing I think
the age of Ultron storyline is a it's an
Avengers property it's a Marvel
Cinematic Universe property the age of
Ultron was the result of Ultron rising
to power taking over the world and of
course Ultron was a creation of Hank Pym
who was an Avenger the Days of Future
past surrounds the x-men group
themselves so they're really not
intertwined and they're held by two
different production studios so unless
Marvel Cinematic Studios the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Fox were to
collaborate I can't really see a way in
which these two universes would cross
over into one another how far did the
movie deviate from the comics who was
the guy in the scene after the after the
end credits okay this is a really good
question I'm actually really excited for
this
the movie deviated from the comics in a
few ways one of course the most notable
example that everybody really is kind of
talking about is that Kitty Pryde didn't
go into the past and in truth I was
really kind of disappointed by this
because I think that Ellen Page is a
great actress and it was really
disappointing to see her kind of
relegated to the catalyst for Wolverine
going into the past as opposed to her
actually going into the past herself in
addition we saw that Charles Xavier is
alive in the comic books Chartres
Charles Xavier was dead he was one of
the three people who was assassinated
which caused the Days of Future past
timeline it was Charles Xavier Senator
Robert Kelly and more McTaggart in
addition we see that it's actually
Bulevar Trask who's assassinated that
leads to the Days of Future past
timeline instead of Senator Robert
Kelley we also see that that Wolverine
of course you know is the one that goes
into the past and we see some characters
who are part of the future and the Days
of Future past that were never in the
comic we see sunspot and the way they
did sunspot I thought was really kind of
interesting it really kind of seemed to
be an amalgamation of sunspot and
Sunfire sunspot was able to absorb solar
energy and turn it into physical
strength whereas Sun fire was able to
absorb solar energy and turn it into
plasma turned into like fiery plasma and
so it looked like a combination of both
those characters kind of combined into
one I didn't really have any complaints
though we saw warpath or I guess a james
proud star and it's really kind of
interesting when you get to his
character because he's the younger
brother of john proud star and if you
guys recall our discussion about the
x-men we talked about how Marvel
rebooted the x-men with giant-size x-men
issue number one in 1975 the
african-american I'm sorry the Native
American and that group is John proud
Stark
that's the original Thunderbird and of
course he died not too long after he was
introduced as part of the original x-men
James crowd saw is his younger brother
and here's kind of a fun fact and the
normal mainstream Marvel Universe James
proud star is actually a character
called warpath
and as warpath he was part of the new
mutants under cable so he's one of the
members that we talked about or he was
one of the members that was part of
x-force when deadpool first showed up in
New Mutants issue number 98 when we were
talking about our dead
Deadpool comic in addition we also saw
blink and actually thought that was kind
of cool to see her character and and
blink actually I thought played out
pretty well I mean blink creates portals
teleports people to different places and
you know for the most part I was kind of
glad to see new characters I was kind of
glad to see that they had taken a step
away from the characters that we had
seen that we initially expected to see
in the Days of Future past
and included some characters that we
will probably never see in any of the
Fox films from here on out so at the
very least it was really kind of cool to
be able to see them and in some former
fashion in a Fox Marvel film as opposed
to never seeing them at all another way
that it differed is that a magneto was
not confined to a wheelchair this is
actually really kind of interesting one
of the ironies that I thought was really
kind of interesting about the original
comic was that where Charles Xavier had
spent so much time confined to a
wheelchair now was magneto who was
confined to a wheelchair and I think one
of the most notable differences here is
the fact that Wolverine talks about how
in the dystopian future you have humans
working with Sentinels and the Days of
Future past comic that never happened
you had no humans working alongside
Sentinels you may have had you know a
guard or you know guards who would agree
or something like that but you didn't
have any humans that were you know
running The Sentinel program or anything
like that The Sentinel program was
running itself
it was autonomous and it was self
controlling and so they were carrying
out their own orders and they were
executing the programming that was given
to them that the only way they really
knew how I thought it was kind of
interesting they included that it's not
really something that I cared for
because I felt like it took away from
the very basis of the Sentinel program
run amok but it really wasn't like a
movie breaking thing it really wasn't
something that I felt like destroyed the
entire movie overall one of your the
cool things true one of the other things
that I thought was kind of interesting
was Bishop and Bishop and will actually
talk about him later because I think
somebody asked a question about Bishop
Bishop was never part of the Days of
Future past storyline he comes from a
future that's very similar to the Days
of Future past but it's not the Days of
Future past so I was really kind of
disappointed to see that in addition we
also saw that in the concentration camps
you had humans and mutants and you had
humans oh I'm sorry you have mutants
that had an M on their face like Bishop
has that is a signature from bishops
timeline that is a brand that
all mutants have so that people know
they're mutants now in the days of
future past timeline and the outfits
they wear it has an M so that you know
they're mutants but they don't actually
have a brand on their face at least not
that I'm aware of there were some other
differences here and there but rather
than go on for 10 minutes talking about
the differences between the comic and
the movie I'm gonna go ahead and bring
this one to an end now in terms of the
the guy at the end of the credits that
was apocalypse and I'm actually very
excited about that I am I'm really
really psyched there was some criticism
some people thought that he looked like
a younger woman and that apocalypse was
actually gonna be a female but I think
it was just apocalypse as a young
teenager I don't really think that it
was apocalypse as a as a woman or
anything like that and even if it was it
wouldn't really matter to me I me a son
is on gender biased on you know comic
book characters or anything but um this
is actually really kind of cool because
we got to see apparently apocalypse has
already gained a cult following he
already has people that are that are
following him now as far as the time
that he appears I didn't see a date in
terms of when this took place so we
don't really know if this is going on at
the same time as the mainstream universe
or if this is going on far into the past
now I could have very well missed that
date I could have very well missed the
fact that it had a numerical date on it
but I'm not aware I'm not sure that it
did so you know I'm assuming that it is
way in the past because we saw the
pyramids being put together so I figure
you know it says when the pyramids are
being established but we also saw his
four horsemen in the background now the
four horsemen are interesting because I
don't know who they're gonna be that
could be anybody it could be Archangel
it could be Wolverine and it could be
gambit or it could be any number of
other characters so you know we don't
really know who the four horsemen are
actually going to turn out to be you
know it's it'll be really interesting to
kind of see how it plays out at that
point in the past I don't think it's
going to be anybody that we know just
because there's really no notable Marvel
characters that existed at that point in
time and that that period and Marvel
Comics aside from maybe Selene killing
the Conqueror you know people like to
have the Fantastic Four that had briefly
traveled into the past try to stop came
to conquer I mean you know we didn't
really see any major notable characters
at that point in time but as I
understand it you know it'll probably
just kind of be characters that'll be
new
and I'm sure that when we see apocalypse
and the current timeline and the a Jew
apocalypse storyline that the four
horsemen will be composed of characters
that we're aware of
let's see continuing down here does Emma
Frost get mentioned at all yes Emma
Frost gets mentioned in passing and that
was actually answered by Gabriel Cruz
Emma Frost mentioned a couple times
she's mentioned once when the younger
magneto is talking to the younger
Charles Xavier and they're really kind
of arguing with each other while they're
on the plane and Magneto's talks about
how Xavier had abandoned them and you
know pretty much all the comrades
virtually all the cast that had appeared
and x-men first class was dead they had
been you know experimented on or killed
outright or whatever the case may have
been but Emma Frost is one of those
people who died the second time that
she's actually mentioned I believe is
when and I think this is actually where
Gabriel Cruz that answered the question
was when mystique was going through the
files of all of our Trask and she was
listed as one of the people who had been
killed along with Azazel and and the
Banshee and it may have been a couple
other people about a number who let's
see